avec nous en direct la nouvelle
présidente de la commission d'avancé sur
recette c'est madame françoise giraud
ancien ministre la culture bonsoir
madame alors j'imagine que vous avez
déjà une petite idée sur votre fonction
votre diagnostic d'abord est ce que le
cinéma français va très mal ou va
moyennement mal non je ne dirais pas qui
n'est pas très mal nous sommes dans une
situation paradoxale en ce sens que la
télévision diffuse 1500 films par an
1500 dans la moitié peut être d'origine
française et que dans le même temps le
public déserté salle et qu'on ne produit
pas parce que le public déserte les sols
il est évident qu'on va se sortir de
cette situation
le cinéma ne va pas disparaître puisque
encore une fois on diffuse un nom tout à
fait considérable de films chaque année
alors un autre probablement s'adapter à
cette situation et il me semble que les
mesures qui sont préconisées qui sont
prises par le ministre vont dans le bon
sens puisqu'elle vise en somme d'une
part à essayer de susciter un plus grand
nombre de films
à grand budget à grand spectacle parce
qu'on a vu qu'ils avaient marché cette
année et d'autre part à susciter le plus
grand nombre de de création et de
premiers crimes dont on a vu qu'elles
ont marché puisque un crime comme les
visiteurs peuvent tranquille par exemple
n'est pas un climat son budget est un
petit film comme on dit qui a
admirablement marché on va revenir à
tout cela mais je voulais revenir ce que
vous avez dit au début
est-ce que vous pensez que la télévision
doit réfréner ses appétits réfréner ses
hommes étaient ou non si elles payent
pour que pour qu'on fasse des films cela
dit jamais le plaisir que l'on prendra à
voir un film à la télévision mais sera
égal à celui que l'on prend dans une
salle c'est incomparable c'est magique
que cinéma une salle de cinéma c'est
merveilleux
l'obscurité les rideaux rouges et enfin
tous les gens qui ont été au cinéma dans
leur jeunesse ce qui est mon cas et
beaucoup d'autres et celui de beaucoup
d'autres et le savent rien de comparable
je suis totalement de votre avis alors
vous êtes présidente de la commission
d'avancé sur recette il faut dire je
crois plus simplement c'est une
commission qui va donner des avances
pour que se fasse des films quels seront
vos critères c'est ça je précise que
cette commission n'a pas été créée et
maintenant elle est ancienne elle a été
présidée à plusieurs reprises de façon
excellente écoute et je ne vous dirai
pas quelles sont mes critères parce que
je ne suis pas ce que je ne serai pas
seul c'était une commission donc il ya
même deux commissions concernant
l'ensemble des fils et l'autre
concernant les premiers films ou les
seconds il ya donc deux commissions
distinctes les jeux je coiffe les deux
les critères vous savez il faut se
décider au vu du scénario et du du
projet en somme c'est extrêmement
difficile
et pour bien le savoir parce que le
scénario n'est pas un livre ça n'est pas
quelque chose de forcément agréable à
lire
ça peut être très bon sens devrait été
agréable à lire
donc il faut espérer que moi même et
l'ensemble de ceux qui voudront bien
collaborer avec moi nous aurons du
jugement merci madame la présidente
merci bien d'autres informations